laughs if it's Haram you want to change
your ways ask yourself are you ready for
marriage if not cut it drop it don't use
and abuse a lot of people say I want to
marry you but you know what three years
three years that's another problem we
face parents have agreed but they say
the marriage will only happen in three
years
these children are literally spending
their life like husband and wife already
and you're just saying niihka will
happen I'm worried about people worried
about people subhanAllah it's the second
time I said it how can you worry about
people when you don't even know how long
you're going to live
you set the trend people will follow
Allah here there was an example of a
very rich person in one of the countries
and he's a friend of mine and I told him
he said I want to throw a party for my
daughter she's the only daughter getting
married and I want to invite so many I
said listen brother if you keep it
simple and set a trend a lot of people
will follow Allah he he kept it simple
and straightforward and he did
everything as per the Islamic and you
know rulings and I swear so many people
followed and I said there you are
brother you get the reward of everyone
they looked at the Joneses and followed
so that the Joneses themselves were so
down to earth who are we
the problem is every weddings become a
competition you know those who are not
even the bride they fuss about the
clothing they are going to wear at
someone else's wedding whom they don't
even get along with sometime just
because they and they have a new set of
clothing sewn and shoes and handbags
accessories and whatnot and he jabs for
someone else's wedding
whereas for your own wedding you're
supposed to be even simpler than that
Allah forgive us and this is why we say
keep it simple it's not supposed to be a
competition and I was told by one of the
brothers well you know what we like all
the sisters to dress up nicely because
we go to weddings in order to find one
for ourselves
well that's not the platform you know I
remember in one of the cultures you know
culturally there are some people who
think when you go to the wedding to
scout you go in Scout well if the boys
are scouting the girls that's not a
religious function right however if your
sister comes across someone your brother
comes across
a decent brother and so on and they
bring the issue up remember you have
sisters to get married if I see a sister
who's old and she's not married I blame
the males who are nearest to her
starting from her father you were
supposed to have kept an eye out you
were supposed to have spoken don't be
shy speak say look brother you know it's
happened to me as well where I've had
young people come to me and said you
know so-and-so so-and-so so-and-so I
have this this this what do you think of
marriage and subhanAllah I will answer
in my own way with respect but I really
admire your courage I really admire your
courage
well I and I believe that that's the
right thing because who knows you will
ask five or 10 people and one of them
who's the right one chosen by Allah will
probably say mashallah let's take a step
further and you might end up getting
married but you've done nothing people
say oh you want to get married make dua
make dua is it like a pot that you keep
on making something no way make dua yes
we will do the dua
but with that we have to act so we ask
Allah Subhanahu WA Ta'ala to make it
easy for us these haram relations to
make them Hallel you need to make sure
that you get the nikah done simple as
that even if you cannot afford to live
with each other now I encourage your
parents I encourage all parents out
there to look into the following
scenario and that is if your children
cannot afford to live with each other in
the same home for now let the nikah
happen and let them live separately no
one said that they have to live together
right now but if the nikah has taken
place and then what will happen at least
the relationship is halal so you are
invoking the mercy of allah the mercy of
allah descends on you this is how you
will achieve if there's no mercy what
are you going to achieve Subhan Allah so
you cannot continue to just say this guy
can't afford a home and therefore when
he has a job with 130 thousand pounds a
year when he's got a car and a house
then we will allow the nikah trust me
they've already they're already living
like I said husband and wife committing
every sin there is in the book and you
know what you're just waiting for 10
years to pass by that time they could
have had children who were already in
the school subhanAllah can I tell you
what a lot of the old people are very
guilty of
wanting the their sons-in-law to be
wealthy people when they married their
own wives who are the mothers of these
same daughters they didn't even have a
pair of shoes you know that so don't
make it a criteria you need a home you
need a house he just needs to be
responsible if he's responsible he will
take care of your daughter like he's
taking care of everyone else so Han
Allah he doesn't need to be a
millionaire well I if that was the case
the hadith would have said either attack
Amanda who mal buzzer we do if someone
came to you they have a lot of wealth
get them married never has that been a
criteria subhanAllah
remember this responsible individual yes
they may have to downgrade their lives
some might be fortunate to upgrade a
little bit that can be taken away
immediately I know of so many people who
are wealthy when they got married and
they lost absolutely everything a little
bit later down the line and I know the
opposite people who were poor they got
married Allah says in the Quran that if
you marry and you are not able meaning
you're not so wealthy if you do that in
order to protect your chastity Allah
will grant you sustenance he will make
you wealthy listening swattin or allah
says 'i know for cara a uni moon
funny speaking about marriage if the two
are poor their intention was to please
allah subhanahu wata'ala Allah will
grant them that financial independence
subhanAllah may allah subhanahu wata'ala
grant us goodness oh please my brothers
and sisters if you're not interested in
the Nika don't use and abuse someone's
child never don't play a game to say
we'll get married in five years and in
the within that time the girl is waiting
for you or the boy is waiting for
example and two years later you just say
not interested you broken their not only
their heart you've destroyed a life
that's what you've done the person could
have actually gone and married someone
else however the last thing I'm going to
say here is that if you have committed
sin in the past you've done Haram and so
on please if the if Allah has made it
such that the two of you are now getting
married seek Allah's forgiveness for
whatever you've done in the past start a
new leaf people have committed adultery
whatever they've done they're now
getting married
they now getting married seek Allah's
forgiveness have your function in a
proper way that will please allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala because what's the
point of having a harem function when a
las facilitated halal relationship
what's the point just have a simple
function beautiful for the sake of Allah
trust me what you need most is
contentment you know all the Haram that
happened in the function is not going to
come to your aid it will actually result
in your detriment to be honest those who
have had functions where Haram has taken
place seek Allah's forgiveness you will
turn and you leave and proceed because
that function is a seed that you're
sowing for the tree that's about to grow
in your life if it's a bad seed do you
expect a good fruit to come out of it
well if you engage in Toba still a las
mercy will grant you good fruit so
please let's mend our ways let's come
out Allah has made it so easy
don't use the cheap excuses I have
spoken to so many parents I don't even
know because of emails that have come in
my direction and I've offered or
volunteered to be a middleman to say
I'll speak to your parents some of them
have sworn me some of them have told me
would you give your own child and I said
yes I would
are you sure they were quiet are you
sure I said yes I would and mashallah a
lot of them have actually given their
daughters and their sons subhanAllah
they've blessed the marriages may Allah
Subhanahu WA Ta'ala forgive us for
having done deled off the path and may
Allah Subhanahu WA Ta'ala bring us back
upon revelation in Milazzo hannah Hatala
simplify all the difficulties that
people are facing in terms of marriage I
support you I really do remember the two
qualities Deen and hope if that's the
case you have the support not only of
myself
but even of a line is Rasul sallallahu
alayhi wa sallam as a community and just
want to finish off this was a dream to
me to have this topic with you inshallah
and also brothers and sisters this video
not video obviously record it's going to
be on YouTube if you've missed out
anything and we re discussing regarding
a lot of troubles regards inner if you
go to my youtube channel I've got a
whole reality show based on this topic
so in sha Allah if you guys ensure you
guys will benefit and before I put a
finish I want to praise others want
Allah the most merciful the most just or
praise His glory and gratitude belong to
him for all the works that we do and
keep us in your door and may Allah grant
agenda for Sharon's platform we have one
more problem how do we get the parents
who we address today to watch the
YouTube clip Habibi scene I pay them can
we pay them some money or something if I
was a millionaire what lie I would pay
them you know why because that's the
problem with the YouTube videos
that's not my mark like they don't watch
it so every time I'm on the platform
like this where there's an audience or
I'm on TV where I know aunties and
uncles are watching their first topic
but I discuss is this the opportunity
that I have if I had the money I would
pay them well a you know aunties and
uncles don't help we want the parents
subhanAllah let's talk to them may Allah
I hope you know what that their parents
in our midst and even later on please
listen to what we've said it's a
passionate plea we're looking for
solutions of the problems of the Ummah
we really want solutions may Allah
Subhanahu WA Ta'ala make us vehicles of
solution to the degree that on the day
of judgement when we arrive perhaps
Allah might just look at that deed and
take you straight to Jenna you know what
you broke every norm that was wrong in
order for you to please me here is your
paradise may Allah grant that to us o
sallahu wa sallim wa barik ala nabina
muhammad salam alayka Robert Allah
Stacy
shoo-shoo shoo-shoo